cobra kai never dies season five
i try to make it work i had no idea this
was out we went to go see uh d strange
two again yesterday and andrew gordon
reminded us or told us for that matter
he's like did you guys catch the cobra
cartridge
what are you talking about here we are
catching up with it uh all the season
four reactions are up here on the
channel full length watch for them for
super sexy rejects over our patreon page
along with a bunch of other shows that
we cover over there you guys can strike
hard that like button that would mean a
lot let's see what's going on in this
trailer
[Music]
[Applause]
you set up a bee
today is a turning point at cobra kai
whoa fancy close-up shot
and the only thing better than a full
dojo
is a whole valley on full dojos
come join us oh my god oh no
this is what we're up against
isn't afraid of putting kids in harm's
way and that's why i have to take him
down you're playing with fire danny
[Music]
of course i do i'll ask around if anyone
saw me fbi
that's the big plan
you all get [ __ ] wrong sometimes females
you always have a shot at making things
right hey
we're not friends we never will be
there's only one way to end this
you have to cut the head off the sink
we have to kill him
[Music]
wowie
wow
[Music]
yeah hey whoa no no what i didn't mean
literally cut his head off
[Music]
do it
it was a language barrier
that's right man always quick to
violence that shows oh man there's a lot
in that trailer an actual
televised commercial to come join cobra
[ __ ] is that terry silver he's got the
gold to pay for such an occasion man
such a fancy upgrade for cobra kai gosh
too much it's like globo gym
too much
too much
sleek and screams
yeah people came to cobra kai for the
homespun aesthetic this is the grounding
nature of cobra kai it feels like a dojo
yeah this dude's taking over man
corporations there's going to be
commentary on that that's what we all
tune in for the political commentary
adam mckay's cobra kai season 5. yeah
danny's gonna ultimately take down terry
silver with just a rivaling ad campaign
and it looks like they're hinting at
this might be the season where miguel
and robbie finally get along with each
other become brothers become brothers
they're going down to mexico to go
rescue him and it looks like freaking
miguel is
i don't want to say getting caught up in
the cartel
but it doesn't focus that much it does
look like one of those movies where yeah
like you know we gotta go to mexico
yeah he's mixed up with all the wrong
people and he's doing parkour and
decking people with bricks of cocaine
it's got that gritty vibe there and then
yeah our two two white people gonna go
in there and save the day that's what we
do rambo and rambo sun
that's right last time absolutely got a
good headband tying sequence for the two
of them but it seems it's like they're
having a fight at freaking miguel's
apartment complex yeah i was gonna say
they must bring him back then i mean as
much as you know he's going to come back
i was a little bit like oh damn we're
going there already you're going to show
us that much and then of course you have
you know chosen and danny here's to see
what he brings to the table here in
terms of the dynamic because i guess he
would still be personally involved with
it it seems like everyone else had a
real personal association to the main
core of this where's chosen's personal
alignment i guess it would be honoree
miyagi yeah it feels like that it's it's
it's like i don't have as many dogs in
this fight as you do but you're
basically my dog in this fight so you
know since we have mended our rivalry
from the past i will then take up arms
and and help you it's just cool to see
him here absolutely one two i mean the
show is great at taking these characters
and then giving them a lot of nuance and
a lot of character story i hope they do
that with chosen and i am thus excited
to see them do that with chosen because
you know there was such a fun reversal
when he showed back up you know
subversion of expectations and it was a
really nice story to watch them mend
that relationship and so i hope that
while he's out here yeah we we get some
kind of personal bonding because i mean
we've seen danny do that with johnny and
i don't want chosen to just be a repeat
of johnny but i feel like there's a lot
you can do there still there's no way
it'd be a repeat he's a totally
different guy he's much more humbled and
aligned with himself he also had this
one shot here speaking of character
nuances but tori looking at her trophy
that false trophy i wonder if she's
going to join cope uh not cobra kai and
join me agido at the end yeah well and
what becomes of miyagido and eagle fang
because they got a rebrand or something
now you know and i bet tori will come
over to the light side and then maybe
begrudgingly you know make up with sam i
think they're gonna adopt her they
i need to take care of her thing that
she had last season tori's gonna get
adopted caused some awkward situations
with the the boy child what freaking
level of this is mind-melding
subconscious purgatory with salmon
yeah that weird void that like the
further for karate you're surrounded by
like the specters of the past what was
going on there i don't know this will be
her this will be her darren aronofsky
season it's just going to be all about
sam like spiraling right right and
turning to drugs and like you know
beating people up in the streets
well it looks good man it's another
season that i'm very much excited for is
it supposed to be the last
i i can we tell those people out there
to make that louder yeah i don't i don't
think the people on the video can hear
quite how much drilling is happening and
that's what people come here for season
five cobra kai september instead of
january yeah i miss sacrificing new
year's eve i know right do this maybe
now we'll just have to celebrate and
deal with that i can't do that oh can't
take a day off for for a national
holiday screw that no netflix premiere
arcane season two on chris on new year's
eve gotta binge it got a [ __ ]
all right guys what are you most looking
forward to hawk he was all over this
trailer yes leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell say hi
to miguel for me last but not least that
cartel thing was not racist it was just
talking about the fact that it evokes
those movies that are borderline racist
hey let's do it
lance door listen man i was thinking
about it who at our patreon page would i
want to apply the three disciplines of
cobra kai to the absolute most it's got
to be you lance you're a firefighter so
instantly that makes my heart sink and i
become intimidated so if we were to
engage in a fight i would strike you
first right in the groin i'm a groin guy
i'm the kind of guy who goes right for
there people say cheap shot i go weaken
your enemy impair them as quick as
possible strike hard then i would really
strike your face hard
afterwards and then no mercy i pee all
over you immediately afterwards just to
really demonstrate how far i would go
to take you down what you don't know is
that i don't drink a lot of water i
drink a lot of acidic things you being a
firefighter would then know i know how
to defeat greg you would set yourself on
fire and then tackle me letting me
incinerate but as we all know
firefighters are immune to fire
so you wouldn't feel a single ounce of
pain and you would just wash it off
right away and look even better than
before you were let on fire so lance
what we've learned is the way of cobra
kai is not the right way
[Music]